[Music]
hello welcome to the honest trailer
commentaries for the honest trailer for
the absolute legend the ultimate boy is
Christopher Nolan Wow there it is yeah
i tota there's a delay I tried to
anticipate it that timing was not
impeccable I'm like Christopher Nolan
who has everything runs like clockwork
precisely yes this is a show this is
your first time watching where we talk
about our thought process behind the
scenes of the honest trailer give you a
little more detail a little more depth
and we're gonna watch along with you
pause give our thoughts and if you stick
around to the end you'll see some
deleted scenes which in this case aren't
many but you know you're here anyways do
late now was almost perfect upon
inception like knowing films themselves
yes well couldn't said it better myself
Joestar Dan Merrill yes Chris I can do
it ago nope too much of a delay one more
now he did not invent the blonde oiz no
that was marketing for instant right
it's not it's not in Inception yeah it's
it's that I think that is falsely Chris
own trailer edited out there's like no
it's the credit for that ya know what's
weird is that like even though I know
that fact I still I think we've now
forced it into her head so much I still
very clearly remember bombs at inception
I did too
yeah not there no but he does have some
pretty heavy scores that are like an
extended blob but that trailer trend of
2014 or whatever everything more
marketing than known more marketing
exactly so let's throw the marketing
aside yeah let's get real
what's knowing what what's Nolan mean to
you Joe or Dan or Joe or me
really well-crafted films about talking
about feeling things okay fan not a fan
oh yeah no no I'm the fan look we we
like to push the the Nolan Brom button a
lot here because much like Logan for me
Logan I also love to make fun of Logan
just because it gets a reaction and I'm
a jerk i I really enjoy Christopher
Nolan's films I don't think they're
perfect but I've enjoyed all of them I
think for Dark Knight Rises but it's
really fun to push that too potent to
poke it's fun dan what's your NOLA
Knight status I as the filmmaker I think
he's one of the most proficient and
efficient and technically amazingly
wonderfully brilliant minds working
today probably the director that most
understands the or at least one of them
the medium of cinema and how to use it
and how to use it effectively and I
think that he also sometimes struggles
with things like emotion and what why we
feel things and not just that we feel
things but his films I think are
brilliantly technical and if stellar I
is a beautiful movie a technical marvel
I just think that it's got something at
the heart of it that it's still trying
to struggle to understand yeah I mean
granted well he co-writes them with his
brother who had different times often
but yeah he's he is crafting the stories
too and I think yeah no one understands
the cinematic experience quite like him
no one else working today makes event
movies that are also original they're
safe for The Dark Knight trilogy I mean
they aren't tied to anything it's just
like he's become the the draw it's like
I want to see what this guy does next
because he's delivered stuff that love
it or hate it and I fall certainly
vacillate not even to either of those
extremes but he you always want to see
what he's gonna do next
he's a must-see filmmaker city puts on a
movie I I have to go see it yeah because
it's going it's meant to be seen and on
a big screen and you know I've been very
critical of aspects of Dunkirk but I
can't argue that it's a stunningly
rendered movie I mean shot scored yeah
everyone down designed
I think the the point that sometimes he
seems to like struggle with emotion and
stuff like that is uh I watch a guy
tinker apart even just individual little
sound cues to like figure out how they
work and figure out how to perfect them
like yeah okay like that's the guy who
also would rather just pull apart the
concept of happiness and like try to
reconstruct it and he's a
deconstructionist yeah but sometimes
those movies feel like machines which is
not a criticism necessarily that's just
no I don't know I call the nola nights
he has as many fans there is a there's a
very dedicated group who don't believe
that he is ever that he's they believe
he's flawless I believe and if you if
you pick it certain things they will
they will attack you with the heat of a
thousand songs but no filmmaker is
perfect that's worthy warmth in his in
his soul went went into the the anger of
his fans yeah he has a very passionate
dedicated fan base and that's wonderful
but also at the same time for those that
might criticize some of his works a
little difficult at times and you can in
see it's some of them seem to take it as
a criticism if you just express
preference for a different type of movie
it's like you you almost can't compare
you know inception and like Sleepless in
Seattle if you're like I enjoy Sleepless
in Seattle more than like you're wrong
no I'm not I just like these movies
better than these movies exactly so that
said we watch them all in a row yeah I
was I once expect just expressed a
preference within Nolan films where I
liked his smaller budget projects better
than his larger button and they came at
me for that so they were like you want
him to fail and not have as much money
when you watch him all in a row I I
won't say the flaws but the the tropes
the moves everyone's got their set of
moves that they they feel the most
comfortable falling back on and those
kind of not us oh yeah no so original
the
[Music]
so it made it easy to write this on
astray it did there was one thing in
particular which will speak of when it
comes up that's a runner that I had
never noticed separately when watching
these movies but when you watch them on
a compressed period of time you realize
that there is one thing in particular
that seems to happen an almost every
Christopher Nolan movie that I had never
put the pieces together discuss we've
seen it well I'm not sure which piece is
talking because of your contributions to
our women in film charity event thank
you thank you for every Christopher
Nolan movie first I was just trying to
head off the criticism you first knew
him as the guy who made memento then he
was the guy who saved Batman now there's
a fancy title barovik films of the
internet's god of cinema makes sense cuz
only God could get the Dark Knight Rises
voted the 66 best movie ever made
buzz it's not no well no but wall-e is
not the 63rd American bees not the 65th
Princess Mononoke from a certain point
of view I'd say it could crack the top
100 but let's be real like the IMDB list
is just a list of the most popular
movies but even amongst that list I
would still say the Dark Knight Rises is
exceptionally high right for what it is
for the other movies that are around it
even amongst that list again I watched
it all of them and it stands out to me I
don't not saying it was an easy
situation or an easy thing to do to wrap
up that story however even given the
caveats 66 is still pretty high for that
it just says I think more about the
people who have logged in and have an
IMDB account than it does about any kind
of
a film critic gives an indication of his
strong online following strong online
following may we all be blessed with
that someday someday yes I want fans is
rabbit is Chris Nolan man kill for me
okay let's keep dance every Christopher
Nolan movie suit up very literally with
Christopher Nolan a visionary director
whose actual vision is red-green
colorblind which explains why so much of
his work as tinted blue watch as he
carefully constructs a series of
intricate puzzle boxes full of nonlinear
storytelling in-camera technical
wizardry units that range from holy crap
that was mind-blowing
- holy crap that blows pretty stupid
it is and I'm sure someone I'm sure
somebody's done it online I don't know I
promise you someone's done it but
rewatching The Dark Knight Rises again
that movie because they set it up
perfectly that movie would have been so
much better served if the movie had
ended with a shot a Michael came at the
table looking off and nodding and he'd
go to black yeah yeah and instead they
do their review it which is like usually
he had the or the studio or whatever had
the trust to like leave it ambiguous
like the inception ending is a little
ambiguous the prestige endings a little
ambiguous yeah it seems like a studio
note I can see yeah I can see Warner
Brothers stepping because it's Batman
you can tell Batman there's children
watching yeah we really got to make sure
that it's clear cuz the kid's gonna cry
it's a pre infinity war world you
couldn't just murder every super ear
yeah exactly but that would have been
much more subtle ending because the Dark
Knight Rises the last image is literally
the new Dark Knight rising but got a
little on the nose there toward the end
of the twist I think that really memento
was incredible prestige was great
although only the first time I think the
second time you watch you like wow
they're really telegraphing this the
whole time they say talk so much about
doubles and Stephanie's for a
Christopher all of his movies
I actually like the prestige I thought
I'd do my favorite Nolan film going into
it and watching them all back again I
think it is actually the prestige yeah I
thought it was inception slash The Dark
Knight but yeah I think now it's the
prestige and not my favorite but don't
sleep on insomnia I'm just like a very
good fun gun loaded yep fully locked and
loaded yeah I guess that's uh that'd be
my ranking is a memento prestige large
drop interstellar Dark Knight Rises oh
wow I mean no Dark Knight sorry oh and
then following somewhere in the middle
there's some fun reversals back and
forth them their little roadmap to where
he would get big be one day yeah yeah
let's keep watching and intense
percussive musical scores they will make
you scream
wha I can't hear ya
[Music]
sorry me a Christopher Nolan protagonist
he's a well-dressed white dude with
brushback hair kind of like Christopher
Nolan follow this intense stoic man
who's likely some kind of thief criminal
or vigilante but who still follows a
strict code but the same thing should we
talk about his brother I guess I already
brought up just interesting point of
fact we didn't go to the trailer we
didn't want to joke about this
it's just crazy because I had no idea
that there's Jonathan Nolan the writer
Christopher Nolan the director and Mark
Nolan or something like that is like a
like career criminal who's like escaped
from prison with bedsheets and like and
like kidnapping and drug plots and stuff
like that lately at large he's like I'm
not sure but there's a third Nolan
brother who's like I don't know how
international but he's like a man of a
criminal man of mystery that just blows
my mind and then it gets you thinking
about like the prestige and the
switching and the ones out in the prison
and stuff like that yeah it kind of
threw me for a loop when I read that
about the possible influence of the dark
Nolan there family of geniuses you have
all use that intellect two different
ways formats anyways fun fact yeah we
did one in the trailer but yeah it's
weird it was crazy yeah who knew let's
keep watching nothing funny the same
person twice never show anyone never
recreate places from your memory always
imagine new places as he reckons with
the tragedy of his past whether it's the
death of his wife
I remember my lifetime the death of his
wife
she was taken from me the death of his
wife it won't bring your wife back the
death of his wife the doctors would have
been having fun assist in my wife's
brain before she died instead after the
death of his wife or when no one really
wants to shake things up the death of
his girlfriend that's a lot of dead
wives what could it all mean the other
fascinating thing about you is that you
work with your lovely wife Emma this is
something that I picked up on watching
through somewhere around probably around
the prestige mm-hmm I realize like wait
a minute if all of these characters have
their motivation is their dead wives and
then it just inception dead wife
interstellar that when you notice it
it's hard not to see it and it is very
like I don't know I don't know if it's a
Hollywood choke there's been a lot of
talk about that about they call it
fridging where it's a shortcut where you
motivate your hero by putting you know
their wife or girlfriend in a fridge
essentially it's easy motivation or if
it's just a trope or if it's some kind
of a I don't I don't know what but it's
really weird it's something I had never
noticed about his movies until you group
them all together like that you're like
oh wow that that happens a lot yeah I
mean there's like a there's a I think
there's good intentions behind it or
warmth intended because I think my guess
is the way he looks at is he's drawn to
these like cold remote withdrawn
characters and it's like what would make
you that way right
oh the death of his wife like somebody I
love so much but that's just a lot of
time fantasizing about it and then of
course the the joke being and that is
it's oh so you saying Kristen I'm not I
don't think Christopher Nolan wants to
murder his wife I just thought that you
know again we're in the humor business
and you're looking for the punchline and
it is funny that a guy that makes a
movie about where his can attend the
movies having a dead wife that produces
his wife was extraordinarily talented
and involved in a road race and yeah it
involved in these movies he has his own
Hitchcock blonde - he just the there's
the Nolan Burnett I think there's like
one blonde and following yes but
otherwise pretty much nolan brunette
yeah the nolan burnett all his femme
fatales and just femme anything or all
brunette ladies it's just interesting to
see these things pop up you said
Hitchcock certainly had the recurring
themes and yeah it's like that's why I
put the line Joe as a cook in every
honest trailer it's like because you
know it's eventually people you can't
hear it really hard to find seriously
actually it's like the will see it's
really hard to find but it's there if
you get sort of a Laurel yeah anything
if you guys tweaked with the audio you
need good speakers we're all saying it
seriously there it's find it weird thing
anyway
Toyota let's go places experience ten
masterfully crafted films that are as
cold and remote as the icy Tundras they
feature where human emotion is not so
much felt as reasoned about I think
positive emotion Trump's negative
emotion every time love has meaning yes
social utility social bonding child
rearing we love people who have died
where's the social utility in that and
where time is just a toy to be played
with whether the stories told out of
order backwards and forwards
simultaneously through an interlocking
series of flashbacks and three separate
levels of a dream where time moves at
different speeds in space where time is
relative or in World War two where time
has just sort of mashed up to make
things more suspenseful and if you think
it's all too complicated
I'll let know and break it down on a
level you babies can understand that's
basically the end of the movie this
stuff is the black and white stone this
is running backwards do is cut between
the piercing there's you know the full
videos for different time some of which
is Carla some of which is black on the
end of the film being sort of there and
those are the ones that relate to a
parallel story be simpler pause yeah I
do want to admit
we were working on email on a draft one
point cuz you were working from home and
you had somewhere in the email it was
like hey guys tags for this or something
and I just saw the clip for a second and
immediately decided that what you wanted
was tags that that just looked like a
penis yeah no I think that was one of
the alts oh was that okay that's
actually what you're looking okay it was
like if you think that's a dickish way
to write a story and then he draws the
day cuz I felt ashamed later where I was
like well Joe no no no the first the
first and usually worst move is to make
the dick joke yeah so but then I mean
it's a little bit harder about it and
then did the time lapse and there were
even because even insomnia starts it
plays a little bit like the thing you're
seeing at the beginning is revealed to
be at the end and Dark Knight Rises
incorporates flashback I think and as we
were going through it I think we decided
the only movie of his that incorporates
like no flashbacks is the Dark Knight
like old I think that's just only one
told linearly like a to be you know
monkeying around with time and reveals
and again this is not a criticism it's
just like that's that's just his his
thing he likes to reveal something and
then tell you later what you just saw
mentor recontextualized things that's
just his style yeah yeah it's a
stylistic thing I wonder what his
fascination is with it if it really is a
genuine thing or is it just like a
technical crutch for storytelling or if
it is like there's something that draws
hims trying to find something he's
trying to find something yeah yeah well
it's also interesting because I feel
like with him he made following and
following his like his handbook not just
for like how he makes movies but he's
like here are the things I'm going to
make movies about these are there these
are the things that interests me rules
you know yeah he's bringing down their
time yeah on linear time and twist it's
just like I'm not interested in like
most of the things I was interested in
you know 15 20 years ago anymore it it
it just fascinates me that
those things man those have just stuck
with him yeah yeah yeah we'll see we'll
see I'm very cursor where his late
career is gonna yeah and dumpling he's
like in his 60s it's gonna be like a
soft kind-hearted old man and like oh he
is 100% directing the max rebo movie no
Star Wars movie stay away you did it you
did your comic book films that don't go
back anyway so keep going so if you love
cinema and enjoy being wowed by a true
auteur cheer for a man who is rightfully
considered one of our greatest modern
directors who sharp cinematic I
incredibly talented pool of actors and
obsessive dedication to the craft of
filmmaking have given birth to a rabid
fans all way that will ignore all the
nice things we just said and focus on
the joking nitpicks which will be taken
100% seriously you know I hate comedian
he's one of the best filmmakers working
today
okay is that not enough I don't know
again using the Joker against us
cultural appropriation for and also my
sister there are two like really
hardcore NOLA nights right now they're
just like I understand humor is a social
utility it's a it's used for bonding but
do not use it against my director like
they're just super summers used for
entertainment yeah don't see utility see
where you really wonder what that
relationship dynamic was on set yeah
yeah oh Linda McConaughey that's a buddy
cop friend she was like you know you
know that like bourbon commercial that
he did where he's just like on the beach
like I want to see that but it's just
him and Nolan on the beach while a jazz
band play kills oh no it's like sitting
there having is a real great team this
trailer and like McConaughey busted with
his bongos like whoo got great energy
today
to be fair this was a serious serious
McConaughey phase yeah there's the
tailored in The Mikado song so I think
he was taking things a little more no
but the rep party is probably a blast
yes let's do some bong rips times a flat
circle women who are secretly evil
Christian a miserable prison Tan suits
snowy layers rich guys buying things I'm
buying this hotel company went public a
week ago and I bought most of the shares
I bought the yellow so let's put a
Christmas together yeah I'm not sure
that they'll let us oh they should I own
the place
clunky exposition where is it a clean
slate were you type in someone's name
I'll tell you talk with a gun near next
now we're trapped in Fisher's behind
back from his own private army and if we
get killed we'll be lost in limbo - my
brains turn to scrambled egg you're a
well-educated man cool and a trained
pilot and an engineer the mask would you
like to see my mask mask you're wearing
a mask just take up that mess you just
take off your little mask it's like
putting on a mask if you're working
alone some days you decide at the
eleventh hour to put Jim Carrey jokes
there's never a bad time to play
samokhin that's how we work there
children
what do you want we shouldn't we get
paid to do this but we do how much Chris
Nolan's masks the comics darker I like
it actually
after seeing Jim and Andy I would watch
this out of a Christopher Nolan Jim
Carrey collaboration no man I think you
collapse under so itself seriously then
I want to watch the documentary
documentary that would be incredible
yeah whoops Oh mask brownie this is
another thing my head I did noticing
there's a lot of water throughout this
even stuff that's not in here about
being on the beach Inception there on
the beach there's a lot of wat water
good tennis player short trains are
drowning her I thought you were gonna
talk about it beginning show that was
the Spence Spitzer who knows why it's
always the Train emotional this is my
bike okay
[Music]
I mean it stands out cuz everyone so
special it also means losing she's the
only guy I have cared for switch cries
echoed thirty so
every Christopher Nolan movie okay I'm
sure you all know about the first
letters when the characters names an
inception spelling out dreams but did
you know that all the astronauts
initials and interstellar spell out BR
CMD which can only be a reference to the
TV show doc where freely Ray Cyrus plays
an empty and his character's name was
Clint Cassidy see see that has to be
referenced to Charlie Chaplin who was
good friends with Edith Piaf the singer
the song an inception that's the cue for
everybody wake up
it all makes perfect sense we're gonna
dream man no one's trying to wake us up
hurry before it's too late the table
just keeps spinning wake up I literally
spent 30 minutes inside the mind of an
obsessive more obsessive movie analyst
little Christopher Nolan Theory there I
buy it well it was a great moment cuz we
were looking for a tag because we didn't
like the two that we had and we pitched
a few and then there was like a
half-hour 35 minutes of silence and then
Dan goes first three sentences of a
Christopher Nolan like conspiracies doc
it was great you did it on your phone it
was BR swell BR CMD I was going like RBC
is at first it was like mr. RBC or mr.
DBC and I'm like that doesn't work that
was RBC MD and then I found Billy Ray
Cyrus oh yeah I found that he was an MD
and I dotted the CC and then Charlie
Chaplin and then they compiled around
together with Edith Piaf and France and
then either from inception in there we
go and we're back at Christopher Nolan
well done sir Wow here Dan yeah we
needed like a conspiracy or a twist at
the end yeah I think you pulled it off
we needed some committed like yeah we
wanted to put ourselves in the mind of
Christopher Nolan but let's see what we
cut out what are deleted that Mike's not
too much right starring just start Nolan
movies describing themselves all
backwards
to create a puzzle you could never solve
the audience knows if you could and you
say what you will about his movies but
no one else in the world is more
dedicated to Phil about 10% of them
maybe that's on digital for various
reasons and I said to Chris how did you
feel about the digital shots and he said
I close my eyes for real though how many
Nolan fans stuck around this long
instead of ragequitting comment below
he's a genius by the way he is yeah it's
just a little too pandering oh yeah we'd
get angry like you're gonna ignore
anything nice we said so well we'll see
and this hasn't come out yet as of this
taping we're doing our long holiday
break or since there aren't many deleted
scenes should we sing our Christopher
Nolan song yeah pan up now pan down zoom
in zoom out Becca Becca what tell me
what this movie is about Chris Nolan
olan olan olan watch Chris Nolan Nolan
Nolan Nolan come on need Wi-Fi it's a
button that says blah wait hang on I
think my volume is just oh okay take
from the hook cuz there's Nolan olan
olan olan olan olan olan olan come on
guys I don't know how we can top that
is easy as Christopher Nolan makes it
look I want to give you props because
before we rolled you had the chorus and
then I was in a whole commentary while
riding the rest of the sample I thought
you were gonna give me props because
this seat which has been slowly sinking
since we started the handle to raise it
back up finally snapped off and this
tool is fully dead so I thought you were
just trying to be cool no I'm not yeah
like Tori from Saved by the Bell
no this is I think that's a good that's
good a place as any to stop yeah oh now
you play if you google inception button
the second one works a lot better just
FYI at home looking for a reliable
inception button good to know yeah a
Russian group get your information every
time you push that it's a what's that
thing from Batman Dark Knight the clean
slate clean slice that wipes your name
from every database on the world all of
a sudden you're gone yes that's the one
not David lo pan the founder of the wing
Kong exchange the guy that's so shady no
one's even sure if he exists next week
is some other dumb movie I don't
remember either oh no it's a recent
release right yeah yeah it's something
that you might want to think to the
laundry yeah congratulations if you
stuck around this long I hope you
enjoyed your time as much as we have
have a great weekend just kidding we're
actually filming this before the weekend
yeah hope you had a great weekend see
you later
you